how do we measure the impact of a film
some measure it fights box office but
for me the true impact of a film can be
as simple as a memorable line or a
searing performance over the decades so
many actors in supporting roles gave us
moments we will never forget I am in all
of Louis Gossett junior sergeant Foley
in an officer and a gentleman
Joel Grey's playfully menacing villain
common in cabaret did VLEs heartbreaking
performance in glory the five men
nominated this year is Best Supporting
Actor have all made a significant impact
with vivid moments that will linger for
many years to come
[Applause]
here are the nominees for performance by
an actor in a supporting role Tom Hanks
a beautiful day in the neighborhood
Anthony Hopkins the two Pope's Al Pacino
the Irishman
Joe Pesci the Irishman
[Applause]
Brad Pitt once upon a time in the house
and the Oscar goes to Brad Pitt
this is the second
his purse
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you this is incredible really
incredible thank you the Academy for
this honor of honors they told me I only
have 45 seconds up here which is 45
seconds more than the Senate gave John
Bolton this week I'm thinking maybe
Quentin doesn't move you about it in the
end the adults do the right thing this
really is about Quentin Jerome Tarantino
you are original you are one-of-a-kind
the film industry would be a much drier
place without you and I and I love etho
she gave cliff booth look for the best
in people expect the worst but look for
the best Leo I'll write on your
coattails any day man the views
fantastic to the rest of the cast and
crew big bad Bob Richardson Robert
Garcia Richie my man Mike Mo you know I
also want to say you know what we're
doing all this I think it's time we give
a little love to our stunt coordinators
and our stunt crews listen I'm a bit
gobsmacked I'm not I'm not one to look
back but this has made me do so and I
think of my folks taking me to the
drive-in to see Butch and Sundance and
loading up my car I'm moving out here
and Gina and Ridley give me my first
shot all the wonderful people I've met
along the way just stand here now once
upon a time in Hollywood he bet the
truth
this is for my kids who color everything
I do I adore you
[Applause]